all right great thank you so much for
the invite to Peter and the D H lab I'm
here on behalf of mosa grave and Arthur
Bellinger here at the medical heritage
library and the Cushing Whitney Medical
Library here at Yale and I'm gonna talk
about a project or part of a project I
helped out with this past summer and
that's been kind of humming away on our
work station through the fall and the
winter so the title is mining the
medical heritage library notes towards a
lightweight open machine vision solution
and here's a quick agenda I want to talk
about what the MHL is and then the tasks
that I was mainly working on which was
eliminating false positive or junk nan
illustrations that MHL was trying to
upload to their Flickr account in their
quest to upload and centuries of medical
illustrations talk about our the
solution that I helped come up with how
it uses deep learning techniques some
results and then some next steps the one
I've been currently working on with
frameworks for sort of collaborative
annotation and forward annotation of
images I want to talk a lot about the
importance of using training data in a
reproducible and transparent way so I
like that a lot of the talks I've talked
about their sort of motivating
challenges so I thought I'd want to do
that as well the preliminary work of
data collection especially when you're
thinking about small organizations or
individual researchers it's very hard
it's sort of thankless it doesn't seem
to connect a scholarship or to be
professionally legible in many cases and
this is especially true when the data
are trying to get you have to download
over a network for instance in our case
that existed on Internet Archive and you
don't already have it lying around and
then you'll do some training and the
model you'll create you might save for
awhile or put on a model zoo as they're
called but the data you actually use to
train that model is often forgotten or
thrown out once you've hit an arbitrary
accuracy goal or
often when you're just left that project
behind so want to think about machine
vision solutions for small organizations
and individual reefs individual
researchers for instance PhD students
like myself what can you do if you need
to move fast and you don't have a bunch
of institutional funding and you want to
maybe even hack something together with
one collaborator by yourself over the
course of a few weeks using one of these
public digital libraries of resources
like the Internet Archive now there's a
lot of tutorials and models and
frameworks out there more than ever
driven by entrepreneurial forces and
Industry and the kind of payment tearing
for all this is still emerging so I'll
try to share some notes on what I've
found work for me and then okay what's
the data we've seen a lot of awesome
Natural Science data
well the data I was working with with
MHL was books which are very messy even
more so than newspapers and periodicals
but they're also incredibly structured
and very semantically rich and
predictable in certain ways that we can
take advantage of and so then a thought
about book data is whether it's better
to curate sets of books and have very
rich annotations in structure for them
or to make tools that work with the
existing major digital libraries like
Internet Archive hoti trust and so forth
and then in this area of extracting and
surfacing historical illustrations how
to find people that are also interested
in this or may become interested when
they find that this archive may pertain
to their own work ok so what is the
medical heritage library well it's was
founded in 2010 and it's a consortium of
different medical libraries and special
collections center among them Yale
Harvard National Library of Medicine
institutions like the welcome in London
and in France and it spans basically the
16th century to the present and it's a
digital consortium so it has a an org
chart but it mainly exists on Internet
Archive as a collection so here it is
and there's almost 300,000 volume
now all of them have been digitized by
the various partner libraries and
scanned and put on Internet Archive
where anyone can download them as PDFs
or using internet archives api's they
can download them in bulk if they have
enough time and enough space so MHL has
a few tools one of them the County
Library Harvard has developed a nice
full-text searching tool that gives you
a little bit more capability than
internet archive itself has but what MHL
puts me about was their flickr project
they are extracting these illustrations
from these historical medical treatises
pamphlets medical journals and posting
them so that the public can view them on
Flickr whether or not this is the best
place to do it that's sort of beside the
point one of the points of this
presentation is if you're given a task
like this how can you best use what's
out there to to make it work so MHL is
Flickr accounts one of them with all
this noisy junk that I'll show you so
these are all images that in the
pipeline they were using were deemed to
be illustrations or to have pictorial
content these are probably from 19th
century books as you can see a lot of
tabular data a lot of textual data was
incorrectly getting picked up as an
illustration and I should just hint a
lot of this workflow comes from
leveraging the OCR or optical character
recognition data so when all these books
are scanned and the text is attempted to
be scanned that generates some estimates
pretty noisy of where there might be
pictorial regions so part of the use of
deep learning for this project was to
pop on a few classifiers at the end of
that pop line pipeline to eliminate
these false positive or junk images and
MHL was actually employing student
workers to go through on Flickr and
delete these manually which was very
inefficient this is the paradigmatic
case for sort of automation through
machine learning is eliminating these
highly redundant non enriching tasks
here's some more of that junk so you see
they do pick up some of the good stuff
but it's more a false-positive problem
there
a lot of junk and so then by the time I
was able to add some filtering to it
we have much nicer results and at the
end if we have time I can scroll through
a little bit of NHL's Flickr feeds all
the remarks that have been made today
about ethics and privacy apply
incredibly more so even to this archive
because you have a lot of theirs the
archive is defined is served by the
bodies of the deceased and so questions
of privacy and ethics definitely come up
okay so existing work on this sort of in
this space or in D H there's been a
digital humanities there's been a lot of
probably the most work on periodicals
and newspapers so the Library of
Congress is a big project the European a
newspaper project the British Library
has something - some nice papers that
have come out recently this one by
Webber's and Smith's uses retrain
convolutional neural networks and I'm
glad all the details of what those are
have been explained so capably before me
and what these Serbs have arrived at is
some basic clustering or finding of
visual similarities or regularities so
whoever's and Smith's working in a Dutch
archive found kind of all the things in
the newspaper that were recurrent like
the chess puzzles or the weather
patterns with these clocks and and Paul
Fife let a team kind of finding the kind
of incredible whiteness as they called
it of the 19th century newspaper archive
in the way it did it's sort of portraits
but there are problems with this when
you're working on historical books or
periodicals as has been already shown
before the standard object recognition
engines are pretty bad but they don't
give you what you want because they're
not attuned to the materiality of the
book as a form and the different codes
and conventions of pictorial
representation within history within a
particular print format so here's some
of the MHL data thrown just yesterday
into to Google and you get all these
sort of valence and emotional
scores yeah head where there are
certainly heads but this doesn't capture
anything about like the really awesome
have some more examples from this text
such as on x-rays in stereoscopy so but
but clearly this sort of off-the-shelf
solutions not going to cut it you need
to do a bit of retraining in the domain
google also fails when you have text and
image which is a sort of the dominant
word image relation with these inline
images in the text within medical
history Grey's Anatomy actually in 1830s
and 40s it's one of the places where you
start to see a shift from full page like
plate illustrations copperplate
engravings things like that to having
smaller images integrated into the text
often made with wood engravings so
another problem with projects in this th
of cultural analytic space is that they
often use data that's already been
annotated which again doesn't really
generalize to the experience of that
individual researcher or that small
group that needs to move fast and maybe
doesn't have that many resources whether
of computing power or money so you'll
see at the bottom a lot of these
newspaper databases have already been
had their their layout annotated with
tools like doc works or Veridian Doug
has done some very clever things he
knows way around this but a lot of the
work uses stuff that's already been
mapped out in other words okay it says
on this part of the page these
coordinates there's a picture there and
these parts there's a column of text
here's a headline so on and so forth but
if you don't have that how are you gonna
do it so and in the data intern archive
does not come with that information you
you're kind of going blind so I
mentioned that the way to cut down on
the size of the problem is to use the
OCR data so here's a sample kind of
random book from MHL it's online on the
Internet Archive and because the
Internet Archive is open MHL is
extremely open public facing
organization you can download anything
you want the raw images whatever so you
can in here's what we kind of do on our
machine there
so we get those initial estimates of
where the OCR thought okay this isn't
text that I will recognize this is a
picture and this has been done by a guy
named Caleb Lee taro I worked the summer
to try to speed it up a little bit and
make it cleaner and incorporate the sort
of filtering step
Latoya's approach and some other people
have been to say okay the way we figure
out when we're analyzing the storica
books where a picture is is we set all
these rules we say well it can't be less
than a 50 pixels wide and it can't come
at the beginning of the book and sort of
all these heuristics about the size the
aspect ratio of the picture where it
comes in the sequence of page images and
we wanted something more generalizable
than that that could find book plates
Illustrated covers pictures of unusual
size or aspect ratio and we wanted to
filter out the junk so this sort of
leads me to my first insight is to sort
of embrace the labeling process itself
so when working with cultural heritage
data especially in the context of these
classification tasks and there's really
no other task other than classification
any technical solution is going to
require acts of historical
interpretation and comparison so the
noisy data like what the MHL was facing
is an opportunity I think to
collaboratively learn about historical
ways of organizing and materializing
knowledge it's not a barrier to be
overcome through a very one-time clever
engineering solution or through hard
coded heuristics so corollary we need as
many people involved in the data
labeling and annotating as possible Ben
Schmidt has made this remark kind of a
more NLP type project but when you're
working with data and we were working
mostly with 19th century data but when
you're working with historical data and
classifiers oftentimes what you're
really looking at is the history of in
many cases library classification
systems themselves or the way that
the various people in the sociology of
the texts that produce the book as an
object conceived of the division and
representation of knowledge so you're
learning about historical epistemology
as you do this work okay so a very
schematic view there's a bunch of
extracted images from MHL and a cloud I
can thank daemon for actually here's a
little logo from this diff cram tool
that'll hopefully show at the end which
provides a kind of way to crowdsource
annotation for small teams individual
researchers and there's a GPU pointing
to the fact that well what do we have
for MHL we had a little bit of stuff we
had a workstation with one GPU and we
had a few months to run it so that's
kind of the basic setup so by the
numbers we started off by kind of doing
a long 19th century project so I said
that MHL had about 300k volumes a lot of
them in the 19th century so we ended up
doing the pretty much the full set of
what MHL had for the 19th century for
1770 to 1899 123,000 volumes we
extracted 2.2 million regions of
interest that's just a sort of neutral
way I don't want to call it a picture
because in some cases it's not you know
there are some errors but they're visual
reasons of interest I'll talk about more
how I trained the model and what I did
when I when I was annotating bounding
boxes around visual regions of interest
in historical books and how I want to do
that better and how I want all your
input how to do that better some facts
about the speed of this what do we use
for these this sort of transfer learning
approach sitting at the end of this
pipeline one of Google's mobile net
convolutional neural networks so it was
a simple multinomial problem I'll talk
about in a little bit you there's all
these different classes of junk and then
there's different things that you want
and you apply this to the whole page
image then you keep the ones you want
throw away the junk and then you use a
mask or CNN or sort of a localizing
accomplishing their on that to get the
actual regions that you want and extract
them from the page and okay in training
so I did all the labeling myself and I
think I did about three thousand before
I got tired for the first stage we're
just saying like haze this page have an
image on it yes or no and about three
hundred for the next stage which is
saying okay here's a bunch of pages with
pictures on them draw a rectangle around
where they are and then let the network
which is trained on like the cocoa data
set figure out you know background class
first region of interest class here's a
sort of schematic so here's a fun book
by Matthew Bailey writer in the 1790s
one of the first works of pathological
Anatomy so depictions of disease the
etiology of it there's a kind of fun
literary history connection the
illustrations for this book here shown
here
we're in William and John Hunter's
Museum in London which was a kind of
basis for a house in dr. Jekyll and mr.
Hyde kind of cool anyway so if you dig
deep on any one book you'll find an
amazing kind of thing so it's almost
frustrating how sumed out this is but a
necessary first step okay so great so
through the Internet Archive API we can
get you know this book is 392 total
pages you know JPEGs and then we use the
OCR data to say well let's cut that on
that there's only 197 pages with a
likely illustration and here's the sort
of taxonomy of classes that we came up
with so we only want to keep certain
classes some are junk we don't we're not
really interested in tables and charts
although there's some cool deeds
projects having to do with tabular data
and diagrams we only want to keep
certain line images plate images and
they were interested in hook plates and
end papers and things like that so now
we've cut down on the space in the
problem a lot so we we sort of have
these Illustrated pages collected now
what they wanted to do with their flickr
project was really have a kind of crop
or bounding box of the images themselves
so that's where the second stage of this
network this masked our CNN came in so
you can now see and when I was training
the data I kind of just went like if you
were to crop this image what would be a
natural human crop of image in a book so
you want a little bit of white space I
went back and forth I wasn't super
consistent or whether it include
captions that's the kind of like very
nitty-gritty question you probably want
a group of people to reach consensus on
and then go for it which is why I'm
gonna showed if Graham at the end
because it's a way of better achieving
that kind of consensus so anyway this is
the pipeline then you end up with 155
visual regions of interest and the nice
thing about this is that the mask rc9
model can kind of decompose complicated
illustrations that have maybe a couple
different parts to them into the
component parts but also keep in many
cases the the full diagram okay we've
talked about activation maps that we
need to do any material on that here are
some examples of what was in the
training data so the junk class
contained a lot of scanning artifacts
you see so many fingers and hands and
stuff it's great and then the inline
image class P I mean we had great
accuracy and precision for this so these
again are this dominant 19th century
sort of mode the wood engraving
integrated into the text of the page and
I'll present a sort of numbing number of
figures here but this is just to show
that yep even a simple problem could
require a bunch of different classes and
the key point is that you learn while
doing the analysis like we got some
things for free doing that doing this
project we now have a model that could
predict oh that's a page
poetry or that's a page of text here's
some stuff from the localization part of
the pipeline the sort of loss or what
you're aiming at is a high IOU score
which is intersection over Union so the
brown there's the union of the
prediction and the ground truth label
and so forth here's the tool I did it in
importantly this tool just runs on your
desktop so I'm interested in showing
different and the time I have remaining
here's some results and it's a more
collaborative tool well what could we
show you can't really show anything
about visual themes or specific objects
at this scale we have millions of images
I know the lab has been working on
putting them into pics plot but you can
show stuff about the format of a book at
scale over a whole century for all of
sort of medical publishing in the West
almost so you find that books become way
more illustrative so on average a book
would be have illustrations that about
one percent of its pages at the
beginning of the century by the end it's
about six percent and what's driving
that well the blue and the red lines are
very closely tied and the increase is
all coming from these inline
illustrations so publishers are figuring
out how to integrate illustration into
the page the expensive engraved plates
stay the same and here's a breakdown by
Sidious okay so as I finish up what are
we moving toward next with the semi gel
project well the age of photography at
scale and we're gonna try to have more
focused experiments on distinguishing
different types of photographic
processes considering more thoroughly
these legal and ethical questions
thinking about advertising advertising
starts to come in to these books and
then representations of disease okay so
I just wanted to show you what I'm using
now which is called diff gram which uses
a four word annotation
oh yeah good this is just a picture from
difficult but she's good so okay so diff
gram allows you to collaboratively label
and you can get some nice hierarchical
labeling so we're interested in this
unit of the figure so that includes the
caption and includes the whole thing but
a lot of books in the first decades of
19th century are have stereoscopic view
so you have the left view and the right
view and you use a viewer so that in
itself is a very interesting category so
I label the two as a pair as a
stereoscopic pair and then I also label
each of these as an extra so and that's
the kind of collaborative sort of nested
archival labeling that you can only do
with one of these new frameworks the
cool thing about DIF Graham is that as
you label it starts to propose better
labels for you so I'm interested in
what's out there in the space and I'd
love to talk after this but thank you so
much for your time
[Applause]
[Music]